more claims against Bill Cosby this time
nine women say they were sexually
assaulted by Cosby right here in Las
Vegas 8 news now reporter Joshua peguero
is hearing from those alleged victims
and joins us with more in studio Joshua
the incidents in the complaint happened
between 1979 and 1992 Kirsten some of
the women say Cosby offered to Mentor
them with their careers but instead they
accuse him of drugging them and then
sexually assaulting them
we took this case with the understanding
that we're prepared to take it all the
way to trial in these
Indies the woman claimed a sexual
assault and battery caused emotional
distress two of them live in Las Vegas
one is Lisa Lublin according to court
documents her assault happened at a
hotel suite back in 1989. Lublin says
Bill Cosby was mentoring her as she was
pursuing her career in acting and
modeling Lublin shared her experience
before Nevada lawmakers I was 23 years
old
when it happened and I had been drugged
and was incapacitated
I didn't know I had been assaulted for
over 25 years she was advocating for
sb129 a bill Governor Joe Lombardo
signed that allowed her and the eight
other women to sue Cosby it removed the
statue of limitations for victims of
sexual assault as much as I would love
to stand up in front of a judge and
explain
to all of you the details of my assault
it still scares me to talk about another
woman named in the lawsuit Janice Baker
Kinney also testified she says she met
Cosby at his Reno home in 1982 where he
drugged her why did I wait over 30 years
to call what happened that night actual
rape because I blamed myself I
re-victimized myself
I was embarrassed I was humiliated
now cos now Cosby was released from
prison two years ago after a
Pennsylvania Supreme Court overturned
his 2018 conviction Kirsten